la scène a de quoi surprendre sur une
route de l'ouest de l'ukraine une
collision entre une moto et une
camionnette s'est produite tout près
d'un convoi de militaires canadiens
victimes bien étonné reçoit
immédiatement les premiers soins par six
militaires venus de loin on envoie ces
jours ci des canadiens dans cette région
de stars ichi ces militaires qu'à la
terre vient tout juste de participer à
une formation de premiers soins tient
réalise empêche ces soldats ukrainiens
ont été sur le front à l'est du pays
pour combattre des rebelles pro russe
plusieurs n'avaient qu'une formation
pièce sommaire s'ils ont vu ce genre de
gars qui on le donne des outils
nécessaires pour sauver des vies pso oui
des collègues et des frères d'armes
c'est l'iran très très enthousiaste
informations
tout près de là des dizaines de soldats
ukrainien supervisés par des
instructeurs canadiens apprennent à
coordonner une attaque au sol appuyés
par des chars blindés pour l'instant aux
tirs à balles à blanc pour passer aux
balles réelles à la prochaine étape
chaque groupe suit un entraînement de
plus de 50
c'est ce qu'on vise envisager les amener
jusqu'au niveau ce qu'ils peuvent
conduire les opérations un peu de la
même façon qu'on fait avec ça proposons
d'être identiques mais il faut juste que
c'est à ça que ça fonctionne et que je
conçois capable de couper ensemble
possède une force éventuelle date de
loterie nationale 3
il entraîne des soldats qui deviendront
par la suite des instructeurs mort pour
former selon les standards de l'otan
c'est l'armée kényane a tant besoin de
formation c'est qu'elle était dans un
véritable état de délabrement quand des
combats avec les rebelles pro russes ont
débuté à l'est du pays
romain nouakchott ambassadeur du canada
en ukraine
c'était une armée en état de désuétude
alors il c'est une espèce de réinvention
de l'armée ukrainienne sur forces armées
de 120 130 milles y avait six mille
effectif comme capable oui capable de
combat au mois de mars 2014 dans un
autre centre de formation à camionnette
modélisme on enseigne la neutralisation
des explosifs
le canada a donné des robots de
l'équipement de protection à ces
démineurs
ici encore on nous parle de l'otan sur
sa souffrance
c'est le but de notre coopération faire
en sorte que nos démineurs puissent
effectuer leur travail selon les
standards de l'otan
l'ukraine n'est pas membre de l'otan des
motifs de tensions avec la russie
c'est ce désir de l'ukraine de se
tourner vers l'ouest le président russe
vladimir poutine a répété souvent que la
russie ne tolèrerait jamais que
l'ukraine fasse partie de l'eau top ce
que nous avons rappelé au premier
ministre ukrainien
franchement je me fous de ce que dit
poutine des outils que le peuple iranien
veut c'est faire partie du maurier bras
l'ouest être membre de l'europe et de
l'otan c'est la seule alliance qui peut
défendre notre pays on est au wales de
kenzy en vacances après l'agression de
monsieur poutine
ils ont changé leur politique et
maintenant ils se sont posé cet acte
d'achat
disons de devenir membre de l'otan quand
et comment ça va se faire c'est une
autre question
il y a un en février 2015 les accords de
celle de minsk ont ramené un calme
précaire sur le front à l'est du pays
entre les troupes ukrainienne et les
rebelles pro russe mais il ya encore
régulièrement des accrochages
la russie a procédé encore récemment de
vastes manoeuvres militaires dans le
voisinage de l'ukraine cette situation
inquiète grandement les pays voisins de
la russie qui sont eux bel et bien
membre de l'otan
l'otan va déployer une force
d'intervention rapide de 5000 hommes
dans la région
les ukrainiens pour le moment doivent
compter sur une amélioration de leurs
armées et les pressions de la communauté
internationale pour protéger leur
territoire face au voisin russe
longtemps considéré comme un peuple
frère difficile pour les ukrainiens
d'oublier que leur pays a été le grand
allié de la russie à l'intérieur de
l'union soviétique à kiev chaque jour ce
monument la mère patrie vient leur
rappeler
il est plus haut plus élevé que la
statue de la liberté à new york il a été
érigé pendant l'ère soviétique est
maintenant bien des gens veulent démolir
cette mère patrie regarde vers l'est
la majorité des ukrainiens sont
maintenant tournés vers l'ouest
et si raymond st-pierre radio-canada à
kiev